hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the most
often read and discussed both by those
who love it and those who hate it and of
course those who are being introduced to
it for the first time parts of Thomas
Aquinas Summa theologia
happens very early in the work it's in
the first part the second question the
third article and it asks the question
and provides answers to it does God
exist this is the article where Thomas
introduces the famous five ways the five
paths VI right and each of these is
supposed to provide an argument from
effects or if you prefer a posteriori as
opposed to a priori right it's supposed
to provide an argument that God exists
and each of them culminates with this is
the case that something of this nature
exists and that is what we call God now
Thomas is going to as always consider
some objections first and then go into
his own view and then provide responses
to the objections and it's very
interesting to see what's packed into
this article he not only provides these
these five different arguments some
rather close to each other for God's
existence he also raises although
doesn't fully address a classic argument
against God's existence that will become
a major part of the literature pro and
Contra within the philosophy of religion
and so this first objection begins by
saying it seems there is no God
why if of two mutually exclusive things
one of them were to exist without limit
the other would cease to exist so that's
a pretty plausible starting point if
there were for example infinite heat
then we wouldn't have any cold anywhere
right or if everything was dead then
there would be no life right and what is
God well among the things that people
say about God is that God is infinitely
good or they'll even go further and say
God is infinite goodness God is goodness
itself from which all other goodness is
flow you can't put a limitation on it as
you can with pretty much every other
kind of goodness so you see where the
reasoning is going there right there
can't be any evil but we look around and
you don't have to go very far and we
discover all sorts of evil all sorts of
bad things all sorts of Mahlum in Latin
a word that can do double duty as evil
or as bad right so if that's the case
then there isn't any God this is
actually an argument against God's
existence that he's considering at the
beginning then he goes on and he brings
up another interesting idea which in a
certain way anticipates the often quoted
Occam's razor right the which is not
actually saying that the simplest
solution is always the best but rather
that entities are not to be multiplied
beyond necessity and you could see this
as a sort of instance of that a special
case
he says if a few causes fully account
for some effect don't seek any more you
shouldn't look for additional ones you
just
getting things in that case now what
about the world can we look at the
things in the world can we look at the
world itself and say the causes that we
know or at least can presume there will
be similar causes to what we already do
know do those provide an adequate
explanation for why things are the way
they are and whether they exist or not
and whether they disappear how they're
related to each other well you know
break it down into two different kinds
of things there are the things that are
natural frogs for example or mosquitoes
or your body itself and then there are
the things that are human creating the
things that are as he says there we go
there they are
[Music]
contrived effects right they are a
proposed seto meaning they're they're
things that somebody thought about doing
for example this this tie or any of the
clothing that I'm wearing or the camera
that I'm filming with or the chalkboard
or I mean we were surrounded by
human-made things aren't we
now we don't need to bring in God do we
to talk about this tie God didn't
directly fabricate this tie some
somebody wove it and then you know put
these things together and sewed it and
cut it and then eventually you know
brought it to a distribution center
which ones who a clothing store
somewhere and then I exchanged some
money for it now it's around my neck
here in this place I don't need God in
that picture do I and so the argument is
well we don't actually need God as an
extra cause for any of the individual
things or for the totality of things
because all of them are satisfactorily
explained by either talking about
natural things that are coming from
other natural things or as he says Roxio
hamana available on toss human reason or
human will so that's an interesting set
of challenges at the beginning then he
brings up an objection and this is a
very famous passage that may not have
been intended originally the way that
Thomas is using it but there's a long
tradition of using it in this way so on
the other hand the book of Exodus
represents God is saying I am Who am I
am being I am you know the greatest
being however we want to frame it right
the being from which all other beings
come so then Thomas will say there are
five ways quincas 'is right by which one
can prove that there is a God and I'm
not going to go deep into each of these
right now instead I'll do an additional
examination of each of these in in turn
on its own but we can look at all of
them and the first three are actually in
some respects kind of similar to each
other
in that they all deal with saying you
have to trace something back from the
things that we observe in the world to
some original let's call it clause
they're all about causality just
understood in somewhat different
modalities you you trace it back to a
single cause that provides an
explanation for how everything got going
it could be about motion or a change
that is going from potentiality to
actuality you need to have some
actuality that can take things out of
potentiality and bring them into their
own actuality efficient cause nothing
comes from nothing therefore we can
trace back as far as we want to in in
the order of causality and we have to
have some original first cause just as
much as we need a prime mover to get
everything going another one has to do
with possibility and necessity that is
the third way or contingency right the
the things that we observe like for
example you watching me right now purely
contingent there's nothing in the order
of the universe that
so that you had to be watching me or
that I had to exist or you had to exist
or this tie any of that stuff there
there has to be some reason why those
are the way they are and we can't trace
it back to merely possible beings we
have to trace it back to something
necessary and that one's a little bit
interesting because he even goes a
little bit further and says well there
could be there could be some things that
are necessary but they're not the first
necessary being and we need to go all
the way back to that and that is God the
fourth has to do with levels in Latin
grados so you could say degrees if you
like either one is a perfectly fine
translation if you want to get really
you know cognate with it just call them
grades or gradations of being and this
is a common idea not just in Thomas
Aquinas but in ancient and medieval
philosophy theology even literature
quite quite across the board that there
are different grades or levels or steps
of being so for example you'd have bear
being and then you'd have something like
living being and then you'd have
sentient being animals right and then
you would have rational being on top of
that and perhaps other levels above that
as well Thomas is going to say that God
is the you could say the highest grade
of being but it's going to go further
than that God God is actually the reason
why there's any grades of being to begin
with and then finally the last one is
really interesting this is a bit
different from the first three proofs
this is a bit different from the fourth
one which a lot of people pass over
because it's a little hard to wrap your
head around and this one is what we
would call a design argument in some
respect it says that the reason why
there is the order and goodness and you
know not falling apart and breaking down
and dying within all the different
things that we observe is because
there's some sort of
national governance some sort of
overseeing and determining of them
that's taking place and what would we
actually call that source of this this
governance you know we can go today says
everything in nature is directed to its
goal by someone with understanding this
we call God and as I mentioned every
single one of these proofs culminates
with the line and this we call God or
yeah here we go Hoke Dickie Moses dayum
that's that's an in in most of these
cases sometimes they'll says qualms old
days damn no me not this is what
everyone calls God all right
so each of these is supposed to be
looking at things in the world and
thinking about them in a metaphysical
way thinking about causality and then
eventually getting to the point where it
says there has to be some fundamental
principle that you know you could say in
a certain respect is the most important
or the original or the beginning of each
of these and that is what we call God
it's interesting because if you if you
do follow this you you could say well is
that what everyone calls God that seems
a bit of a stretch and another attack
that has been made on this is saying
well I mean what we mean by God is not a
prime mover or you know the governor of
the universe or the highest degree of
being or you know the necessary being or
something like that it's the God of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob the god of you
know scripture or something along those
lines and that is a an objection that
you could make at that point in the soma
tale oh yeah let's go back to this ugh
these two objections so God is infinite
good that means that there shouldn't be
any evil what does Thomas do as a
response to this well he takes off from
Augustine and he says Augustine tells us
because God is supremely good he would
not permit any evil in all his works
unless he were sufficiently almighty
and good to bring good even from evil so
Thomas draws a conclusion from this that
this is actually a sign of the infinite
goodness of God he's good in a way that
goes beyond our normal conception of
goodness in that he can in fact allow
there to be some evil in the world
precisely because he brings about good
through it so he says it's a mark of the
goodness of God that He permits evils to
exist and draws from them good is this a
very strong objection to the problem of
evil no but Thomas is not concerned so
much in this article with refuting that
he's more concerned with the five ways
isn't he
the second objection actually kind of
fits in to the five ways as Thomas notes
you know there's no need for extra
causes don't bring in the god hypothesis
you might say so you make things even
more complicated and Thomas says well
you know when it comes to a lot of
individual things maybe you you in a
limited framework don't actually need to
bring in God but if you're thinking
about the totality or even if you're
thinking it through all the way with
these natural and artificial beings that
were surrounded by then you actually do
need God in order to complete the
picture
he says natural causes act for definite
purposes under the direction of some
higher cause so that there are facts
must be referred to God as the first of
all causes why for example does
digestion work the way that it does you
could say well it's evolution it's you
know all these different things coming
together you come up with all sorts of
interesting scientific explanations and
Thomas would say yeah great that's
really interesting is that the
fundamental cause for why say digestion
works the way that it does even the
process of evolution you could say if
you're willing to do this as some Thomas
in the 20th century have been well what
structures that what actually governs
that it's got to be some sort of
intentionality some sort of intelligence
even if you say it's completely
allowed it to be random like that I mean
there were getting a little speculative
going beyond the text but he says in in
the same manner contrived effects that
is things that have been that are coming
from human conceptions human plans ex
propa CTO all of them have to be
referred to a higher cause than human
understanding and and and will for these
are changeable and can cease to be and
all changeable things and all things
that can cease to be require some first
cause so if you want to say well the
reason why all of these human-made
things are the way they are is somebody
at some time thought about it and
decided to do things that way that's
great what made it possible for there to
be a human being to think and to decide
there has to be a first cause for that
notice it's not saying that the first
cause is in any way directly causing the
human thinking or willing it's just
saying you want human beings to do
thinking and willing you got to have a
cause for that right and you can't trace
it back indefinitely there has to be
some first cause and this is what we
call God so the second objection
actually leads right into Aquinas --is
five ways which and here's the last
thing I'll say about this the five ways
can be understood in an apologetic sense
as ways that a person would prove to him
or herself if they're doubting or to
another person who doesn't think that
there is a god ways to prove or
demonstrate that God exists that's the
way Tomas arranges them they can also be
understood in a deeper sense as ways for
a person who does believe that God
exists to better understand what God is
they're not providing a rich conception
of what God is of course in saying that
God is the first mover or God is the
first cause or God is necessary being
that's not telling you a hell of a lot
but it is providing some advance in
understanding of what this
thing that people are calling God would
in fact be so the arguments or the ways
are really providing two different
things there's an apologetic ground to
it or purpose and then there's you might
call it a get to know God sort of
direction to them as well
you